good afternoon
i'd like to welcome everyone to our
fourth
endeavors colloquium this semester
um and it's a glorious day for several
reasons
not least of which being that we're
around the bend
with the election and it's really great
to come together
and think about the meaning and power of
art to guide us through moments like
these
um i'm jacqueline goldsby i'm chair of
african american studies here at yale
and i want to point out that we have two
more sessions to
present in this series of discussions
we've been holding all
uh semester next thursday on november
19th
which is a thursday right not this is a
special day but on thursday november
19th at 11 45
to 115 one of our newest faculty members
in african american studies professor
philip gough
will detail the groundbreaking work he's
been doing
directing the center for policing equity
and there's a way in which the center's
work is kind of aptly summed up
in one of its mottos doing data science
for racial justice
and professor goff will unpack what that
uh
phrase that idea means and how his team
has put
that principle into scholarly action
and political activism around the
politics of policing so that will be
next thursday
and then on december 10th i believe it
is
yes another thursday uh from 11 45
to 1 15. another new colleague professor
elizabeth henton
a wonderful brilliant historian will
team up with a long
time ally of african american studies
professor tracy mears of the law school
and they're going to map out the work
that's happening at the justice
collaboratory which is a research and
policy action center
organized by law school faculty so those
are the next two events and we hope to
see
all of you there um the department chose
to dedicate the semester's colloquium
series to
issues that would be decisive to the
outcome of the presidential election
and beyond because we know our work is
not done
even though the election went in the
direction i hope
most of us wanted to go um
but just to review for those of you who
haven't been with us these past
weeks um the challenges of securing
voting rights and theorizing new models
of citizenship which we got to do with
latasha brown
who directs co-directs co-founded black
votes matter
black voters matter is tremendously
still
alive with us as an issue the delivery
of justice advancing health care
to the formerly incarcerated their
families and communities
was an amazing discussion that we held
with
emily wang who directs the center for
health and justice
out of the yale school of medicine and
today again we're going to be
thinking about the enduring and evolving
role of art
in making social justice thinkable and
actionable
with our extraordinary panel who you'll
meet in just a minute
i want to thank our co-sponsor the
center for
the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration
who's been co-sponsoring these events
with us and
the director of rhythm professor steve
pitty and his associate director
matthew tanika have been extraordinary
colleagues with us to make
all of this come together i want to
thank them
i also want to thank our staff vanessa
epps who's been
incredibly diligent of just stepping
into the work
publicizing and getting these zoom links
out for all of us to congregate here
together i want to thank her for that
work
and emmanuel bissell who's here with us
today
managing of the zoom room to make sure
that all the connections work the way
they should i want to thank them both
for their support of this initiative and
now i want to turn it over to my
colleague professor crystal themester
who's done a brilliant job organizing
the series and she'll introduce today's
panel
thank you jackie and i also want to add
my gratitude
to both vanessa and emmanuel
for all their support in making this
happen and
working with me and just making sure
everything
runs smoothly and for um particularly
vanessa i haven't said this but helping
to design the beautiful
flyers that we have for this series um
vanessa put a lot of work into that and
i think they're really beautiful
so i i want to just give her a shout out
for her work on that front
um but i also want to thank all of you
for being here today
um i know like um myself and
many others um retired um but i think
there is joy and much to celebrate um
and i know that i've been inspired
in the last couple of days in ways that
i haven't been able to find
inspiration in a while and um and i
think that
you know part of our celebration
i feel like this work um these artists
that are with us today
are going to inspire us with not just
their words and their art
but with their presence and remind us
that the ways in which we can find
beauty
and joy in the struggle so i am so
grateful that they're going to be with
us today and holding this space for us
so before i introduce them i want to
remind folks about the format
we will um allow our participants to
engage
in a robust and full conversation for
about 45 minutes around four o'clock
i will um sort of give them the nod to
go ahead and start opening up for
questions we take the questions
in the chat ideally we would love for
you to send those
questions comments to claudia rankin in
the private chat
and she will sort through the questions
and
really present them to our um our two
gifted
artists scholars intellectuals um
to respond to um so i'll ask that um
you you do that and make sure you keep
your mics on mute
um throughout the conversation um and on
that note
i have the great honor of introducing um
three wonderful scholars and artists i
want to begin
with my colleague claudia rankin
she is the author of five books of
poetry including citizen
and american lyric and don't let me
be lonely three plays including help
and the white card her recent collection
of essays was just published by
gray wolf press in 2020 titled just us
an american conversation and in 2016
ranking co-founded the racial imaginary
institute
and among her numerous awards and honors
rankin is the recipient of the bobbitt
national prize for poetry
the poets and writers jackson poetry
prize
and the fellowships from the guggenheim
foundation the macarthur foundation and
the national endowment of the arts to
just name a few
and we're really um lucky and honored to
have her leading this conversation today
we also have reginald dwayne betts
one of a friend and a colleague and a
co-parent in this community
that we call new haven so it's a real
treat
to have him um in afam um
in conversation with us today he's a
renowned and published poet
speaker and leader in public defense and
advocacy
bets is the recipient of numerous awards
including the 2018 guggenheim fellowship
and the new american fellowship
bet's writing has been featured in the
new york times the new yorker
and the washington post betts is
currently leading the million book
project with my colleague elizabeth
hinton
and colleagues over in the law school
under tracy mayer's leadership over
there
and that initiative which aims to
transform the role of literature and
libraries
in the lives of people in prison is um
is is in in the making they're doing
that work now
um and and finally i want to introduce
titus kaffar
also a friend
and a member of this new haven community
that we're really lucky to have him here
he's an artist who's painting sculptures
and installations
examine the history of representation by
transforming its styles and mediums
with formal innovations to emphasize the
physicality
and the dimensionality of the canvas and
materials themselves kefar received an
mfa from the yale school of art
and is a distinguished recipient of
numerous prizes and awards including a
2014 gwendolyn knight and jacob lawrence
fellowship and a 2018 art for justice
fund grant
and the 2018 rep report prize
kevara's painting analogous colors
2020 was featured on the cover of the
june to
june 15 2020 issue of time magazine
which included a report on the protest
sparked by george ford's killing
at the hands of minneapolis police
kaffar's work is included in the
collections
of the museum of modern art of course
the yale university art gallery
among many others far has two
forthcoming exhibits
and one of them actually might be open
now in new york but
he can talk about that and in belgium
and on that note
i'm going to turn it over to dwayne who
is going to
share some images with us um so
we can all be on the same page
cool yeah how's everybody going doing oh
this is zoom y'all can't even talk back
to me huh
they came in i'm uh i'm gonna share my
screen and then
we'll walk you through a few images and
uh and then we will start the
conversation
thank everybody for coming though so
what you see here is i'm just going to
walk through some of the um the pieces
that were in the pleating freedom
exhibit so this is one of titus's pieces
and really i'm just going to show you
the
images i'm not going to try to explain
it or talk about them i'm just going to
run through
and those are the pieces
thanks wayne hello everyone good
afternoon
it's i was up on the rock today it's a
beautiful day
so it's nice to spend the afternoon with
you
um i and i bring up being on the rock
because i went on a walk the other day
and i was telling
someone that i was walking with
um that i was going to talk to dwayne
and titus today
and they said oh dwayne and titus
they met at st thomas i don't even know
if this is true
but the story i got was that
because their children went to the same
school
they became friends is this at all true
either of you no
i can't see titans but no it's not true
it's not true okay
it's okay i mean everybody has to have a
mythology created about them so we could
just say
that's that i met them how you met them
well i i like that story because i like
the fact that
um that it was the generations that your
kids were bringing together
you two great guys um and
and amazing artists in the world so but
okay it's not true so there it goes
um i'm gonna have to go back to that
person and ask them where they got that
from
um the um the pleading freedoms
exhibit which is the sort of catalyst
for this talk
is a talk that i thought we could rename
this discussion in this way
that um our conversation is going to be
about erasures redactions
and other critical creative
collaborations and endeavors
by the both of you and um
and so i wanted i wanted to begin by
thinking about erasure
you know it's a it's there are many ways
to enter
into that and um and it's been
a very sort of hot topic because we've
had
in circulation a lot of videos
around black death and black suffering
and so i was really interested in
beginning
with the consideration
of how each of you sort of
walk the line between artists and
activists
or writer and activists relative to
the creation of work and and then the
second part of that question would be
how does the act of in
um engaging either erasure or redactor
from archival materials play into the
practice
yeah that's an interesting question i i
think um
you know i wonder about the first piece
you had on the times magazine
uh cover titles because i sort of feel
like at least for me it was a bit of
reluctance actually to try to make my
art
immediately reflect in the moment um
to try to speak to the immediate moment
the concerns that were on my mind
as a citizen in this country and i
remember
actually you know yeah eric garner
yeah michael brown and you just had his
wave
you know and um and i'll just speak to
the two specific poems
and how they came about and they came
about
as first that it was i was resisting
trying to be the poet that right
that writes about the thing that's
happening right now because in some ways
you end up getting a
a slogan instead of a poem and and i was
writing bastards at a reagan era
and my full intent was to try to engage
with this
question of violence and how violence
was working within our country and
within our communities and specifically
within the world of incarceration that i
understood and my friends
and uh and i just remember driving the
ruckus for a talk
and when i came back i think somebody
got acquitted on the way back
and we got word of acquittal or
something and it was just in
in that moment that i ended up um
just having to change one of the poems
that i'd written i had to
rethink it and really seriously take
into consideration
what it was that i was trying to say and
i know i had one line in it
um you know it sort of framed the
conversation but i know i had one line
in it
and somebody's throwing a trash can
through saul's window calling that
revolution
while the bodies still roll off the
blocks and into the prisons
and into the graveyards and um and so
for me
the whole process was an act of like a
reluctance of reluctance of reluctance
until
um so much of resisting the moment
forced me into the moment and allowed me
i think to get into the moment
in a different way and the tamiya rice
poem that i wrote was the same it was
sort of like
i'm not writing a poem about this i i
i'm not going to write a poem about
the police murder and to mayor rice
until
um i told a friend to write a poem about
something they would never read in
public
and at the law school they got this wall
where everybody could talk and and like
i had wrote this poem
and i was so mad at the discussions that
were going on around
um what was happening and i just i have
wrote the poem
a few weeks ago and i was never going to
show anybody and i just posted it to the
entire law school
as if that's how you publish a poem and
i thought that is how you publish a poem
you know when you write a piece
and you want the community where you
live to hear everything that you got to
say and the poem was kind of
kind of raw actually i hadn't even
really worked on it too much it was just
there
it was the same thing you know you know
how do you and in fact i wrote that to
speak about saints
i was really thinking about what it
meant to drive my kids to school
and a really privileged school in a
really privileged place and i was
thinking about how
how we got a whole we got far too many
black folks who own
a kind of suffering and fear that their
lives don't embody
and and i felt it was something
grotesque but i still think it's
something grotesque about that and it's
like how do i work my way through
these issues while acknowledging that it
is a fair amount of privilege that i
that i um carry
every day into the world and so part of
that poem was me trying to confront that
and trying to say you know
despite the privilege i'm still a black
man driving his two children
his two black sons to school and the
death of a
the murder of a 12 year old it was this
was planned on repeat in my head
and so um so anyway these poems for me
come out of a reluctance
and i'm not really activist in any kind
of way i try to get people i know out of
prison
i've decided that i just need to
simplify my own terms so i'm in no way
activists really i just try to get
people i know out of prison
okay titus before you go um don't
answer the question i just want to
follow up with dwayne on one thing
when you have written so much about your
own life as somebody
who you know your last book is called
felon so in some ways
don't aren't you turning yourself into
a um
metaphor of the system of mass
incarceration
um so that the the subject of your work
becomes not it's both
personal and public at the same time
and as personal as you get
i mean i just you know the piece about
um in the times where you bring up your
mother's story as well as a rape victim
it it seems to me that this idea that
you are reluctant to move
into the realm of
um of the devastated
um and victimize black person
within our society might be
useful for you in the creation of things
but
is not necessarily true in terms of
where you're going in terms of your
subject
it depends because it took me 10 years
to write that piece that i that i just
published in the times
i mean a literal and you know 10 years
to
to and really you could say 15 in terms
of knowing my mother's experience and
then even
beginning to write about it and if you
go through the trace the
the through line of my work you'll find
me dealing with sexual assault
a lot and you'll find me dealing with
domestic violence a lot
but but that's me taking half steps to
the thing that i wanted or needed to say
so i would argue that
it's like yes and no you know i would
argue that um
and even in the poems i write in first
person a lot but part of it is i believe
that um
i need to figure out a way how to
situate all of it in the
in the lyric eye because i think
anything else ends up being me
i'm willing to embrace some of the
hardest things i write about so that
when it's somebody that's inflicting
pain there's always somebody else that's
doing it it's not me
so even when you read felon it is a fair
amount of it that's me but it's also a
fair amount of it is written in the
first person that's not me
and most of those poems i mean they feel
i hope they feel fresh and i hope they
feel immediate
but i mean a lot of that work has taken
like years to get to
and some of it is not about me at all
and so but but but what you said that i
whole holiday agree with is the point is
the juxtaposition of the public and
private to create something
that i feel is like fully political but
i feel like that work
i try to honor the work that activists
do and just sort of like acknowledge
that that's not what it is that i do
and frequently i'm just lucky that my
work is
is like the disconversation about harris
and sexual assault
and also getting friends out of prison
like fundamentally that piece is talking
about
two people who i can name and i could
pull up a screen share parole packets
that i'm working on to get them out of
prison right
like that work feels like it's utter
moment right now but i've been working
on those cases for five
six years i mean i've been working on
trying to get them out of prison before
virginia brought parole back
and so it's it's a way in which you can
read it and think oh man dwayne's on
point he is right in the moment
and the truth is nah i'm just i'm just
lost in the moment that i got lost in
you know when i carjacked somebody on
december 7th 1996.
okay thank you um what about you titus
how do you how do you walk the line
between being an artist and an activist
since your work
speaks directly um as as
timeless as the pieces are they're still
historical they're still
um critiquing they're still engaged
in many of the vibrant questions we have
now
uh so i think one of the things that
dwayne is getting at is
and one of the things i think we're
eventually going to get at is um
just this idea that the political is
personal and personal and political
i think eventually we're going to come
around to that somehow
um i the the piece that
duane referred to the first painting
that was in
in the time uh in time was
it was editorialized as something that
was very much about ferguson
but uh ferguson was a secondary it's a
b-roll um to the a-roll um
in terms of what the painting is about
the painting is about
me getting stopped by the police with my
brother that's what the painting's about
the painting's about my personal
experience being in chelsea
i've shared this a lot where the police
officers
uh stopped me and my brother while we
were walking down the street and put us
up against the wall plugged guns on us
and accused me of stealing art out of my
own show
right um and so it's
it's personal and i think for me that's
the hard part
um like what you were saying before
dwayne is like uh
when at that point in my practice um
that was
actually that was the point in my
practice where
i my my work was no longer
private um because up until then
i'm just a dude in the studio making
stuff that nobody really cares about
anyway
um i'm just trying to figure out what's
going on in my head
and then that that work came into the
world
and all of a sudden i found myself
being public in a way that anybody who
knows me knows that i'm not like super
comfortable with
um and so i think what dwayne may be
resisting
is this idea of us as
activist symbols um there's a whole like
symbolism that goes along with that idea
that i'm just not
i'm in no way interested in um i'm
interested in the work
i'm interested in justice i'm interested
in understanding my role
in the world um but i
i i read too much history and seeing too
much history
to know that to be comfortable with the
way in which
people want to put you in on a some kind
of a different pedestal
as a as an activist just to wait for you
to slip up and fall down and then
and then like have some overjoyed
expression when you
when you when you fall um
yeah the other thing i want to say is
like uh
know that story is not true about how
i've met but but and i know jason
stanley's on the line who always wants
to take credit for us meeting each other
um but i'm not gonna let you do that uh
but
what i will say about that story is our
friendship is rooted in
our fatherhood um i think
that um our that is dwayne and i like
our connection
is deeper because we are both black
fathers trying to figure out how to
raise our kids
and we are raising our kids
in realities so different from the
reality that we grew up in
um our kids have no understanding
of the struggles that we
went through when we are their age and
in some ways we don't
necessarily want them to fully
understand that they shouldn't have to
go through that
um but i think that that's a fundamental
part of um
of our relationship um we talk a lot
about
about being dads and what that that
means so even though that wasn't we
didn't meet at st
thomas in that way both of our kids go
to saint thomas
and so it has become a very important
part of our relationship
thank you for that um i i i also want to
pick up on this
reluctance um around
the naming of the work as in any way
activists because
i i wonder um and i wonder this from my
own personal
position there has been a tendency to
name
work that is done by black people as
political work
and that has been out there as a way
to denigrate the work in an odd way both
is
um flattering and and saying that oh
you you're involved in what's going on
you're on the cutting edge of
politics in america but on the other way
it's a way of saying it's not white work
it's not transcendent work it's not work
that is able to really address the human
condition
and how all of us are one thing
and blah blah blah blah blah as if there
is
um a lack of investment in whiteness in
the work of white people
and so i so often i i
see um artists
who are of color running away from that
that way of talking about their work and
i
wonder how con how much
think about or fear the idea that people
will use it as a reductive measure
around your work whether it's the
writing or the
the the paintings yeah i think the first
i just read i read i just reread um
please don't let me be lonely a few
months ago right
i'm like yeah don't why do i keep adding
please
if you put please it's a song well it's
the every
it is a song but maybe
it may be you read that book and and um
and um and yeah oh and what i was
thinking is uh
sean bell you know i'ma do diallo
i mean i mean the work is laced with
that and it's beautiful work and it's
not
work of a time you know it's work of
time you know you go back to it
and it keeps delivering a richness and
so you know if somebody pick up citizen
they like
yeah you know this this poet claudia
rankin is really political and i'm like
but claudia rankin always been claudia
rankin and it's just you know
how do you approach the the breadth and
the length of the work
and i think it becomes productive both
ways i tend to not care what white
people think about my work like
like that's not even what i'm concerned
about about how people are reductive in
that matter
i'm concerned about the the people who i
know
who think that my calmly hurts piece was
supposed to say what they wanted it to
say
you know who feel like oh yeah i've read
your piece and what i just don't
understand is
you don't know that kamala harris is a
cop you know who wants slogans from me
and that's why i resisted i i've
resisted because
yeah man look i shouldn't even tell this
story i'ma tell it
hold on go ahead go ahead because you're
gonna do it
i'm i'm i get invited to this gig here
yeah i'm i'm some such and such right
and um and i'm having lunch with the
folks and they say uh first story is
like
it was so brave of you in your book to
to admit that you sexually assaulted
somebody
i was like oh [ __ ] what book
huh and i knew the poem they were
talking about
and when i wrote the poem the people who
published the poem the first time is a
crown of sonnets that ends felon
they called me and they were like do you
know in this book you admit to raping
somebody
and i was like i'm absolutely certain
that i didn't admit to doing that
because i've never done that
and i could have told him i'm absolutely
certain that i didn't admit to doing
that because
i feel like that's the worst thing on
this planet you could do given the
experience of women and my family but i
didn't want to go that route right
and i only say it now because i've
written a piece and it's out there
but this person was trying and they they
needed to connect the poetry not to
something
that was deeper not to something that
was raising the same kind of questions
or the right white artists that they
teach in the classroom
they needed to connect it to me and it
was no reason for them to have that need
to connect it to me
like i don't read you know i don't read
emily dickinson and wonder if she did
the things that she did and that work i
just don't read poetry that way
and i know that i've been constantly
taught that you weren't supposed to read
literature that way
but it's a strange thing in which the
the the writing
of like black greatness gets reduced
wholly to the personal and there's no
imaginative force
this is what they tell you i i wish
i lived the kind of life you live so
that i could write like you
you don't [ __ ] wish you lived the
life i lived and you can live the life i
lived and still can't write like me
but that is not what they say to ashbury
i've never heard somebody say
ashbury is just the profound suffering
you've experienced allows you to be a
great artist
like that is not the way we approach
white art and i feel like it's not just
like
the white community or the white world
or white critics who do that i feel like
unfortunately
as many people who want you to be a
jukebox
and and they choose the songs that they
want you to sing and they don't read the
work as expansively to allow permission
for other things to exist within that
work like they don't say why does
that poem have a speaker who says what
that last poem says because that's not
important
what's important is how they could
characterize me
and they were dead wrong you know and
i'm gonna start saying that every time i
meet a white writer i'm gonna take the
most absurd thing that's been written in
the book and say
i can't believe that you feel that way
about your mother
me like like like it's just an absurdity
things that i i would never imagine
doing
that that people do well you know first
of all you know what they said about
ashbury
they said we don't know what the [ __ ]
you're writing about
they trashed his early books because
they were so obscure and part of the
reason they were so obscure is because
he was at yale
and he was gay and he couldn't admit
and right from that positionality so he
had to create
a kind of vague um subjectivity that
could move through those poems but
that's another day in another
conversation
what about you titus i think it's
it's interesting because there is
difference because i'm making images i'm
making pictures um words and pictures
are very very very different and so
i make images which
requires not requires that's the wrong
word
um compels people
to want words i mean sometimes and
sometimes
you are making images because you're
trying to
visualize something ineffable something
that doesn't have
words um i start for me
i start i explore all kinds of ideas of
course
but i do i do start from a place of like
where do i connect to the story
whether it's like directly
uh uh autobio autobiographical is a
different thing
but for me it's like how do i connect to
the to this story
and that's something that's something i
think about a lot the other thing is you
know
right now uh everybody wants to talk
about black artists having a moment
um and it's funny to me some black
artists that they're talking about
having moments have been here
for like 50 years but they're now having
a moment
um i'm not really interested in
the i'm not interested
in trying to make work let me put it
this way
the revolution i'm fighting for is not
one where everybody makes the same work
as carrie james marshall
his work is amazing but that sort of
figurative
um work that speaks uh directly about
the reality of black life um is not what
i'm fighting for or even people
making the work that i make as i think
about this in the context of
next haven what i'm interested in is
like the freedom
to make whatever you want to make what
you talked about claudia was this idea
that
black folks not being able to make
something uh that feels universal
that's really what it comes down to if
donald jug can make a black square
and explore minimalism in that way i
think our folks should be able to do the
exact same thing
and so i uh i'm not
uh i'm i know that in my work it's going
to continue to evolve
uh to evolve and so i'm going to do all
kinds of all kinds of different things
um but that is that is actually the
freedom that i want
is just that that ability to explore
whether it's abstraction minimalism
um figurative whatever whatever it may
be
um well that brings me to the practice
and i'm
because i'm really interested in
the pleading freedoms uh process
and um rushenburg robert rauschenberg
he erased de kooning's drawings in 1953
and jasper john's referred to the idea
of erasure
as additive subtractions
and i i really love that term
that in the erasure we saw in the
initial images
and i guess i can see them behind you
dwayne
um that that sense of going back
into the archives and erasing in order
to add
in order to extend the um
the cultural um
readability of the of the the document
so i'm wondering if you could speak to
both the why both of you have gone
in the direction of redactions and
erasure
how you think about it when you
um are doing it whether it's painting
the whitewashing the painting or
using tar to cover um the face
or to redact as you did in those in
those
pieces behind you yeah i was thinking
about
i mean first i was thinking about press
forevers great novel oration
and you know and one of the things that
he does is uh
you know he creates this character
that's writing a fictitious novel he's
like a judge for a big award
and he's frustrated with the way in
which people think about
the awards to come through so he quickly
pins
uh a fake novel um about black life
and what he does i think it's a racist
order the complexity out of black life
within that novel and he expects it to
flop but then it ends up winning the
prize that he's judging and it ends up
being
like wildly successful more so than
anything he's ever written
and so i tend to think of redaction
beyond a ratio because i think about it
ratios
i think about a ratio as the way in
which you could [ __ ] the
understanding of a subject
by by by thinning it out to justice it's
a stereotype
and i think the law as a whole i mean
when you take that whole legal document
i think so often the law as a whole does
something
to um to to like frustrate our
understanding of really complex issues
with all of the words that get added so
i like the notion of um subtraction as
addition
because i was trying to think of you
know sort of independent and related to
the work that me and titus
were thinking about really i was just
trying to understand the law
in such a way that i could convey it to
my folks and i thought
you know what if i redacted what if i
just argued that a lot of this stuff
doesn't matter and i just get and i
wasn't trying to do this in a way to
transform the text
to say something else but i was trying
to do what person ever
did but flip it you know so instead of
writing the novel
that that that makes you aware of all of
the
um the the disingenuous ways we view
black life what if i
got rid of all the legal leads to make
you aware of what's really at stake
in these cases and um what was
more troubling to me is how many pages i
could get rid of
you know i would start with 70 pages and
end up with 10
and i would start with 70 pages and end
up with eight but the beauty of it was
um
and part of this wasn't just me it was
the the lawyers who wrote these
briefs they thought it was really
important to find a way to bring to life
the men and women who were suffered
under the system of money bill
or really under the system of
incarcerated people because they were
too poor to pay
you know if i wanted to summarize it in
a sentence whether you talk about
traffic tickets
or bail or mining fines or fees and uh
and it's cool though because as a lawyer
nobody understands
the the bandwidth for the stuff i do
with my family but they understand
things like freedom
and i think these pieces allow me to
sort of tell a story in such a way
that um that my folks would get it
thank you titus i was interested in
redaction as mark macon
you know one of the things that dwayne
and i talked about when we started
working on this project is how do we
collaborate on something
that doesn't diminish either the image
or the text and so usually when you have
when you have collaborations with um art
and text
sometimes one of those things becomes
the
the superior and and we wanted we wanted
that not to happen and so the redaction
itself
the process had to be it had to be
brush marks right it had to be a part of
the
the work itself the the painting itself
and so redaction just became
uh the the go-to language for us because
it was a part of what we were
all what i have been doing uh for for a
long time
um redaction was uh for me in the
paintings if you think about the
painting behind me
um it's a way of focusing my perspective
focusing my attention
um giving myself the opportunity to
to move some other things in the
composition to the side
while i explore um a quiet idea
that hasn't really had the opportunity
to have the volume turned up on it
um so in some ways redacting is the
opportunity to turn the volume up
on other parts of the composition
so um titus if
if the collaboration caused you to
wish to equalize image text
inside these pieces how
is that different from when you're
working on your own
with the white washings or the cutouts
um i have to trust
i have to trust that the
redaction the sort of formalized
redaction
that is dependent on the content of the
poem that dwayne is making
is still aesthetically functional
so i that what we what we found is
it always was it all was always
it was never a problem we were redacting
things
so the process of making these pieces uh
duane can you possibly share the
your screen and shared that um the image
of the two
larger reduction pieces
so um dwayne takes the text
and the legal document and then he
rejects it down
um but you got to say too though right
because part of it is like
it don't work if if you get a print and
you have to read the next print
to understand the content so i almost
had to make it
like a haku like like like it's a
sequence but each one has to stand alone
so if i was to read this one when you
get to 25 dollars per day
cleaning a city scrubbing feces and
blood
from jail floors like that's a wrap and
we could go to the next thing
but that's a complete idea in itself
because again it has to be some kind of
literal integrity with the words on the
page and the actual page itself
yeah but in each of these pieces each
each piece is actually four pieces so
there's a portrait that i uh
etch onto the panel and then print then
a second portrait
that etched in print then we silk screen
the text and then we silk screen um the
redaction
and so we're we're seeing each layer of
this uh individual piece come to come
together
and after looking at it again and again
what we realized was the deconstruction
was interesting in itself
so we started doing these pieces where
we were showing the individual layers
because it helped you understand uh it
helped you understand
how the work functions when they're all
together we tried
initially doing some redactions where it
was more
um a digital redaction and we realized
very quickly that the hand
was necessary and so dwayne redacted
each one of these lines by hand it's
subtle but it makes a huge
difference that those lines are not
precise that they are hand made they
angle slightly they wave they undulate
um that's that's all really important so
again it allowed us
it allows the viewer it allows me as a
first viewer
to move back and forth between the the
faces
and the redaction as marks and the texts
all sort of in balance with one another
i also like the fact that from the
get-go it suggests a kind of partial
justice
that um the act of redaction means that
we're never bringing
the full force of the text to
the plaintiff or to the moment in a way
um but i i but i understand also that
there were other
other ways of um thinking about
it do do either of you um
think about um
[Music]
counter narratives as a strategy for
the work that you know dwayne you said
you don't care what white people think
or
or it's not a frame you're working
against but
are you thinking as you know it's 20 20
we're making work
all of us um and and and this is also
true i think
for those people who are doing academic
work or
that there's a way in which a thing has
been told the story has been told a
picture has been set
and then there's another way to do it
and and i i feel
like the choices that both of you are
making
are actually critically
engaged to disrupt and
and prevent certain kinds of readings
that heretofore determined
the narratives around certain subjects
yeah well i mean well maybe i think a
more correct way i could have put my
statement is that um
i care what everybody thinks but i'm not
concerned with
trying to perform for a particular
audience at a particular time
right and so it's almost as if you know
the first poem i mentioned
um house of ending
it's almost as if that poem which has
some
some some moments that can be read is
literally about me
but also has moments that can be
obviously read is not about me
is that almost as if that poem sets up a
narrative
that that that um that then i can engage
and get at
with um the common hurries piece even
though
when i write house of unending i'm not
even thinking about the kamala hurts
piece
so yeah maybe that's true but i just
don't think that
first of all i think as a poet the one
beauty of poetry is that
any collection is filled with narratives
and counter narratives
but i think the other beauty of the poem
is that
um unlike memoir is that i could like
bring my imagination
to explore and explode the the sort of
uh
tension between the narrative and the
counter narrative and to be quite frank
often i'm not certain where i'm
positioned
within that conversation and i kind of
think and this is the difference between
me being an artist and me being an
activist is when i'm representing
somebody on parole
you know you got two murders and we're
gonna work to get you out of prison
and this is how we gonna tell this story
and this is who you are and yeah
i'm honest about it you know i think
that they are i believe in them
but if i didn't believe in them my
narrative is set
and i think as an artist you know
my intentions don't have to drive what
people take from the work
it's a it's a certain kind of freedom in
which you know i could do my thing
and let it live in a world in a way
that's not um
that's not solely driven by what i want
a
audience's response to be and that's
quite unlike i think
the work i do when i represent people on
parole and i think that's like
closer to activism than my art because
when i represent you
i know what we want the outcome to be
and i know when i failed
the only time i fell as an artist it's
like when my son was like
yeah you can't say that i'm like huh
he's like yeah you know
that line right there where you called
yourself a fella i don't like that i
don't think that's true
like that's when i feel as an artist
because because somebody who i wasn't
even thinking about
as my audience has like cut
into my thinking in a way that makes me
feel like yeah i could have thought
better
and that's the fairy of artists i think
at least that's my favorite
artist when i find that like i could
have thought better in my art and i and
i didn't
although i kept my line because i ain't
gonna let no nine year old edit me i'm
just not with that
i want to throw this in there too uh i
want to get to the
counter uh narrative in a second but um
this is something that duane and i think
about a lot we're working on this other
project together this film project and
a couple of weeks ago dwayne was in the
new york times for a piece that he did
and i was in the new york times
for a piece that we did and you know
those pieces were reviewed by different
people
but who doesn't get to review our work
generally our
generally is not reviewed um by our
mothers
um and and and the people that they sort
of represent
and so what we did was we actually had
our mothers
interview each other right that's that
to me
my mother's thought on my work um is
sort of symbolic
of like my community's thought on my
work in that way
um that's something that i think about
like you know
i think way more about what you and
dwayne think about my work than i think
about what the new york times
or whoever's reviewing my work is my
work i'm fine with them hating
everything i do i'm not fine with y'all
hating everything i do because
because you know my intentions right you
know me you know what i'm trying to get
at in this thing
i mean so if i if i if i uh if i fail on
that stage that's a
that's a whole different kind of uh
calculus
um so i am looking at the counter
narrative that is something
that i'm interested in but i'm
interested in it in the context
of me as the first audience
how do i want to see it and that evolved
in me because i had to learn
in graduate school that um the
professors
uh critiqued what i was doing quite a
bit that's the nature
of the mfa program at yale and
i didn't have a whole lot of allies when
i started cutting holes in paintings
i didn't have a whole lot of allies when
i started watching paintings
those same professors now are very
interested in what i'm doing but at the
time that's not it so i had to figure
out whether
i wanted it or not whether it felt right
to me or not
knowing that they're not they may never
get it right
and so that's when i'm saying like when
i sort of push back on being
a uh a sort of activist that's
that's kind of where some of that some
of that comes from because i feel like
it's necessary
for me to prioritize my conception of
the piece
my understanding of the piece before it
goes before it goes
off but you know what's crazy though and
i should admit this
is i did a whole lot of work too saying
um artists
should work more with activist
organizations and non-profit
organizations
and did some work raising money and
trying to build those connections
between those organizations and artists
but my point wasn't to turn artists into
activists my point was to acknowledge
that we all live in this community and
that i do think that the work of
activists
and the work of government officials
would just be much
better if it was more deeply engaged
with art and i do believe that you could
do
that without becoming you know
propaganda for a machine
and i think that some places across the
country have have begun to think about
that
but but you know it's interesting i mean
you talk to public defenders and they'd
be like
a lesson before dying who
who who is that and it's like oh
how do we really do this work and how do
we really feel
a deep connection to the people who
deeply do this work when they literally
sometimes will only support things that
you do and say
that follows the company line that they
want to push you know i got friends who
were like you know we were colleagues we
worked together
and i saw that response to my times
piece and i was like all right
we aren't actually friends we aren't
actually colleagues
what you wanted was a like you wanted
you wanted a puppet and because i
wouldn't i wouldn't
back the the things that you were
whispering in my ear
you don't want to support the piece
you're not retweeting it to your
audience you're not engaging with it
and i get it i'm not mad but now i
recognize that you're part of the
problem because soon as
my community's justice is not in your
interest
then my community's justice won't be on
your agenda and i think that's that's
one of the things that i resist
um although i work really hard to get
people to care
let me add one piece to that this
political conversation
like just recognizing that you know it's
all going to be political in some way
and and that
i think that uh part of the reason why i
also push back on this idea of being a
political artist
is because i don't want the work
to not be understood formally as well
you are a you are a a great poet not
simply because of what you talk about
but the way you talk about what you talk
about
how you do it the formal structures that
you manipulate and use
and change and alter the rules that you
use and the rules
that you break when we talk about
political art
the formal part of the art goes out of
the conversation
it's like no you didn't spend 20 years
learning your craft and trying to figure
this out and creating a language that's
functional for you
what it becomes is like a conversation
about the politics
and i know i mean going back to what
dwayne said about like first person
writing in first person i know that
there are some times where like you'll
look at a piece and you'll go
this is an amazing piece i'm not sure if
it fits the politics
but this is an amazing piece and this is
something we struggle with when we look
at art history itself
there are plenty of pieces that we look
at and we go politically this is off
this is really off and at the same time
i'm struggling because i recognize
that that is masterfully executed so i
just think
i think for me i i want there to i want
to live in that tension
i want there to be this difficult place
i don't want to just hold on to
one yes titus kafar political artist for
no titus gafar completely formalist i i
want to live in some place in
in the middle
um that is a great place to open up the
discussion
we are at four o'clock and um i see
no questions in my chat um
perhaps there's a private chat crystal
that i'm supposed to go to
but in the chat function there are no
questions
um the people haven't put in their
questions but this is the moment for
them to start
um they can send the um a question to
you in the private chat
that would be great um but they'll start
doing that now
while we wait for that to happen maybe i
can ask this one
last question because by by talking
about
your both of you as as artists
important artists contemporary artists
who
engage um
issues of our time
it's not really an attempt to call you
um political artists it's it's a it's a
way of saying
it's what is great about the work
is that it does not um shy away
from the realities of our lives
and those realities engage
um many of the political hot topics of
now so it's just
part of what the entire picture
of the life's work is
um so it's it's but
but the but i understand that um
we're constantly in that fight not to
um have that word political
engagement um reduce the work
and its achievements and its its
excellence and craft and all of that
but i would no doubt in a minute be to
be to be the
like poet in residence at the national
at
you know um for sheryl and eiffel
like i i would like um
i would like no doubt be like like if
brian stevenson was like look man we we
need a
suite of poems like robert hayden did
when he was he did that suite of seven
poems called burn and spear
man i'm hyped at and i want i want to
commission you to do something like that
so i guess what i mean is this is a kind
of superficial engagement with the work
i've been i haven't been writing the
same poem since 1996
but i've had the same obsession since
1996 because when they take a 16 year
old and put them in solitary confinement
for 10 days without giving them a bath
it tends to stay on your mind for a long
time
so i've had the same political
obsessions because when you know men who
got sickness this life
at 15 you know and they stay your
friends when you're 40
those become your obsessions but i think
one of the things i just want to make
clear about is
i'm not interested in a reductive
characterization of my work
you know if we want to have a real
back and forth about what it means to
connect the things that i write
to the struggle to to end the
over-incarceration of people in this
country
if we want to connect the things that
are right to achieving social
justice among multiple spectrums right
then i'm really deeply invested in that
but what happens i think is a lot of
times people just want a superficial
engagement
you could turn on the news and you will
not i like you i won't turn on the news
and see claudia rankin in the middle of
the discussion about
addressing um you know like even
something as basic as microaggressions
and people will like name drop your book
and and and and they will be like
and you will say well we're having this
conversation about michael brown
you know we've been talking about this
for a long time for decades
and and my work wasn't in the center of
that conversation because the people who
were doing social justice work chose
not to have it in the center
conversation or maybe not the people
doing social justice work
but just out inclination as a country
and so
i guess what i mean is i don't want to
be this the like step
i like step children so i don't want to
use that metaphor i don't want to be
like the
handmaiden but if you say handmaiden
that's that sounds really scary right
now
i don't want to be that off thing you
know i want to be an integral part
of the actual work that's going on in a
way that i feel like
you know grapes of wrath was you know in
a way that i feel like uh
you know other texts in the past like
like really existed as like a
fundamental part of
the work that was being and maybe i'm
just being idealist and maybe they felt
the same way
i feel but but i sort of just feel like
i feel like i'm not
you know i feel like i'm always
embarrassed about how little
you know lawyers i know know about the
your work was the first work that
somebody was like
yo wait have you read this book citizen
and i'm laughing i'm like
all right i'm glad you're reading
citizen but what made it profound was
that was like the first time
that people in law school was carrying
around poetry books you know i was
thinking about literatures thinking
about
and so in titus's work is one of the
first times folks is like
yeah man this this guy you know poets
that we know is like
you know this guy titus kaffar and is
being a part of
the landscape of the conversation but i
want i guess i just want not to be
an afterthought and so that's why i want
to claim that i'll read the story and
then move to the question i was in
wyoming getting on one of those little
planes that
you know terrify everybody and
this um guy said to me he's a poet
so it's not totally out of the blue but
he said to me
have you heard of this guy dwayne beth
and this was before this was like i
think even before
your first book came out um
so i think i think you
you shouldn't underestimate the power of
poetry out in the world
dude sounds like a genius though he
sounds like an exceptional human being
he is jenny tang um wants to know i
i wanted to ask about their investments
um both of you
in portraiture and relation of portraits
to history
and subject hood and subjectivity and so
i guess it's both about
you know the use of the first person
that would be another way of thinking
about it but you want to start titus
yeah uh
my favorite historical work is
portraiture
um like i go to it first when i'm at the
museum
uh but you end up seeing
at least i end up seeing people who
don't really uh
look like me and we're all arrogant to
some degree
and we're all looking for ourselves and
images
um and i i wanted to understand how to
paint my skin uh and so
usually as an artist what they tell you
is to go to the masters
right and that's how you're supposed to
learn is to go to the masters but i
recognize that the masters hadn't
explored on what i was trying to explore
and that the occasions where um there
were quote portraits
of black people there were more
caricatures than there were portraits
you know if you were painting someone
you loved you wouldn't paint them like
that
that was my experience of looking at
portraits in the museum
uh and so i i spend a lot of time still
thinking about
uh the representation of people not as
not as a traditional portrait i mean i
have one behind me
which is a character study which is the
big version of the small one that's
uh in your in your spot claudia actually
i'm i also make portraiture where you
don't
see the face at all where you may just
see
this the silhouette and it's a it's
it's a way of addressing what wasn't
there
what you didn't see but it's still
acknowledging that there was
a black presence even though i don't
have the
[Music]
features to be able to articulate that
there are no existing
or historical records or details about
those individuals
and therefore there's no way for me to
like put that down on canvas
and so sometimes what that looks like is
just a completely
tart out face um or a silhouette
of an individual that stands in for
someone
i wish i did know
you know i'm just going to add you know
sarah lewis's work around
frederick douglass and how he
was the most photographed man
of the um 19th century and that
his intention really was to put
images of black people men
out there using his own image you know
um but just to
proliferate just do it so that when you
close your eyes and you think what does
a black guy look like
it turns out he looks like frederick
douglass and and so
so in a way that impulse to
to shift away from those um
um images of gary types
of enslaved people into
a different image becomes you know the
ones you see walking in the street
and yeah becomes uh so i'm gonna do the
next
question um and then um dwayne you can
take that and then we'll
just switch back and forth so we can
cover as many questions as possible
this one um so cara sarah i'm gonna
um skip your question go to jason's
there are several
what seemed to me problematic
dichotomies here
on the one hand mr betts draws a
dichotomy between
the personal and the political and the
personal can be
very political but i want to ask mr
kaffar about a dichotomy
he drew which also seems to me to be
real
but also misleading between the formal
properties of art and its
excellence as political one of the ways
in which mr khafar's work is outstanding
is that the political message is not
didactic and overbearing it seems to me
that here it's not just that the formal
excellence
it's not just about the formal
excellence
it's going off the screen
plus an important political message the
fact that
his art is not didactically political
has something to do with anesthetic
properties
over and above the formal work political
excellence in arts is not
just having a good message i'm i'm
wondering if he would speak to this
aspect of the work how the aesthetics
and the political combine to make a
political message not didactic
so dwayne if you started with
um thinking a little bit about the
personal and political again
and then we move to um
to um titus's separation
of of those two things as well
yeah but i think even the separation
counts for my work i mean uh
you know you read my poems you got blank
verse you have
guzzles you have cestinas
you have can zones you have a crown of
sonnets i mean you got a lot of
um formal attention to like
i mean arguably i'm i'm like a legit
formalist you know i mean i'm like
arguably uh you know one might say that
i favor form more than that
i think though thinking about the
personal and the political and
and i think about the way that the art
is perceived i guess
one of the distinctions i'm just trying
to draw is between
like i frequently just don't know what
i'm going to say when i go to the page
and and i'm just trying to draw that
distinction you know i write
even even some even the kamala harris
piece i i don't know what i'm going to
say when i go to the page and and
in the process of producing art is the
one rely on some of the
the formal skills i have to push me to a
truth that i didn't have when i started
and um and i think too to try to reveal
something
about the thing that i'm writing about
that that that
astonishes me so so i guess
my i don't know if the dichotomy is is a
real dichotomy or not except i'm trying
to
distinguish between i think like gossip
and gospel and i think gossip is is what
you trade with friends on street corners
and gospel is when you hear a story from
a friend on the street corner
and you have to say it again and you
have to say it again
and the meaning for saying it is because
you think it just makes the world feel a
bit better
by by having told that story again you
know and i i like to believe that the
poetry
rate does that but i also like to
believe that it does that because i
don't know what i'm gonna say going in
you know i think what you're saying um
that is incredibly important
and as a fellow poet i totally totally
agree with this is that
the creation of art really
doesn't have intention in it and that's
what makes it
creation that the act of creation is
happening in the making of the things
and and and intention has to do
with having an agenda which is how we
think about political action
and and acting on that agenda towards
that agenda that's why they say you know
like
my agenda here is woman's choice and
then they go
and do the many different way you know
approach that issue in those
different ways what about you titus what
are you what are you thinking about
um i think the reason the person sees a
dichotomy is because
that's what i'm trying to that's what
i'm trying to say i'm trying to say
that i'm i'm i'm trying to do both
i'm trying to exist in both and as soon
as you look at something of mine and you
think of it as a
political beast stop doing that and
think of it as a formal piece
then stop doing that and then think of
it as a political piece like i wanna i
wanna be bouncing back and forth
between this i don't want you to feel
comfortable calling me a political
artist and i don't want you to feel
comfortable calling me a formal artist
i want you i want you to exist in both
of those space and like
you know it's difficult for us to hold
these two different ideas
in our hands at the same time but i'm
asking you to do that because that's the
way i approach
work and it does have to do with this
idea of process
that if i'm in the studio and i'm making
a painting but in this painting
what i politically believe is not
is not is not highlighted but
formally the thing is blowing my mind
the painting's done and so i have to
wrestle in myself
with what to do with this other sort of
political stuff that's like not working
but
i i i have to sit with it right because
what i've learned from my process
is what dwayne is saying half the time i
don't know
i just don't the first time i balled up
a painting
i had no idea what i was doing no clue
at all it made no sense to me i just
knew
i had to do it period and then i balled
up the painting and looked at it and
went
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is like
i don't i don't even know what i'm
supposed to be doing with this
and then i came back a week later and
saw the same thing and went oh
oh my god there it is right so i cannot
be the kind of artist
that puts arbitrary restrictions on my
creative process
in order to fit some political agenda
because
i would i would diminish myself as the
creator that i'm
attempting to be i'm still who i am
i still you know the personal is
political as we talked about before i
still
hold the like spiritual ideas that i
hold i still believe the political
things that i believe
and that is going to find its way into
the work
and i trust that i trust that and to the
degree that there is like
internal conflict in the work i believe
that that's a valuable thing
like there's we are we are conflicted
people
and if my work doesn't reflect some kind
of internal conflict then i'm not
reflecting
myself so then in a way
and i and i agree with this the word
artist is a verb
and it it is constantly influx
um and you know i i don't really have
the same
thing about political work because i
feel like
i but i'm what i'm um there's no way to
pull out the politics from the reality
or from the life you just cannot it's
it's like saying i can
put it on at five o'clock and take it
off at three o'clock i cannot
i cannot especially not as a black woman
i cannot and so
there's no way for me to go to the page
and work
without all of that being in the flux
of the the creative um process
of the activity of the verbness of the
word artists
you know so i would say that i
so i wonder if there is a parallel
in the visual art world and the poetry
world i don't know
but my experience at yale was
zero conversation about the political
aspect of what i was doing
zero conversation about the social
implications
of what i was doing and then
once in a while someone from another
department would come in and try to have
a conversation
about that in our critiques and it would
be very clear
that the room was not prepared for that
conversation
but then what ends up happening is there
is a
and i'm not saying that this is good by
the way i'm just no no no no there is a
way
in which visual arts
can people will purely review the thing
based on its like formal aspects and the
conversation it's have
oh you you know this is a conversation
with abstract expressionism and
you're thinking about um de kooning and
you're thinking about you know all of
these things that we can have a very
very long conversation about that
and not one time not one time
talk about the black character or we can
have the opposite conversation
where we only talk about the fact that
there's a black character there
and we don't talk about the fact that
yes in fact i am in conversation with
takumi i am having a conversation about
abstract expressionism can i always do
that all the time
poets do that all the time but i think
we're both
what we're talking about i think when
you say that
when you talk about the world the the
historian the art historians the world
of critique
we're talking about standards put in
place by white people
who have decided that as much
as the work looks like their work that's
how good it
and x that's how excellence is
maintained
and created and so to have to
refer to black people
as a political force or as a human being
that's a whole nother so you can't
really you know there's a great um
essay which might be of interest to both
of you
by denise morell she she talks about
um manet's um olympia
and how all of the critical work done up
until now
gave a sentence to the black woman in
the painting
it said the black woman in the painting
and the cat
have no significance but if you
and then she went back and looked at
many's
archives he painted three paintings of
that black woman
he was interested in her role in paris
at that time
but white art historians in their
myopic centering of whiteness
dismissed even his intention even
money's intention
so that yeah i've ever i've read i
listen i watch the lecture
yeah yeah yeah her book is um i i didn't
read the book yet but it looks
fascinating and i caught
i caught the lecture that she gave about
it yeah no so that's i think
but i'm gonna end with the last question
um sarah smith
i would love to know more about what
titus mentioned
was the difference between how audiences
approach
works of art could they both say
more about the expectations that
audiences bring to visual art versus the
written word
separate question how do audiences take
account take into account
the breadth and length of the artistic
process while also accounting for the
ways that
the artist writer changes over time
so questions about um audience
audience and also um the
the breadth of the uber of the uh
the artist i think i think the first
question we've been we've been
talking about the whole time really i
think there's a different expectation
though
for for painters and poets
i think i mean don't neither one of us
have an audience
i mean this is like this is like the
reality of it right we having this
conversation
i think the poets have no audience no
painters ain't got no audience i mean
this is real
like like like one of the things is like
that so you know
to figure out how to have people
have art in their homes and think about
art and that's what i mean me inside is
doing a book for the redaction because
we like
we want the book in people's houses so
that is it's a part remember with crowns
crowns came out about 2005 2006
and it had a companion book that was
about black women hats and i was working
at a bookstore during that time and it
was flying off the shelf
we didn't have any art books in the
bookstore right
um but that book was flying off the
shelves because people in the community
was really interested
in this book about hats i think oprah
might have featured it or something
but i think the reality is that like we
both struggle with having a real
audience
it's just that we got to do the wu-tang
thing where we just produce one copy of
our book
and sell it for 15 grand you know we we
we we doing
like we satisfied with this thousand
print run 2000 print run
i think we we got to do bigger but the
last thing i'll say about audience
though
which is i think it's part of what men
titus have been doing with this project
and thinking about
you know as we produce this book and
thinking about making it accessible to a
larger audience
and having pleading freedoms in a
neighborhood in new haven where art
usually doesn't exist
is is bringing it more to the people and
for poetry i think um for me my
challenge is
how to make sure i give a good show and
then how do i make that show
exist in in in spaces that could like
have more people come to see it and that
is like a real challenge for me is to do
something that's enjoyable as i turn
felon
into into a solo show um with the
intention of saying
i'm gonna be on broadway you know with
the intention of saying how do you
produce a piece
that that like demands the audience
somebody in this season look somebody's
flexing in the chat room like
i have a copy of crowns and that's what
i'm talking about where you you you know
we're like
that book existed where it was on the
bookshelves like it was a bestseller
and um and so anyway i want my poetry to
live
and communicate to the audience in that
way and i know i didn't exactly answer
the question but i think
i i want to cut through this discussion
of audience and say
what is my the product that i produce
the art that i produce
what kind of audience does it demand and
and my continued challenge as an artist
is to is to make it demand a bigger and
a broader audience
so that they actually can be a part of
the political landscape and the
political conversation in a way that it
might just be
nipping at the outskirts right now well
genia
and sandra both have a copy of crowns so
you're speaking audience is a is a
it's a weird thing right so you know
we're talking about
the the schools of thought that review
our work right so let's let's be honest
i'm trained in a very
european tradition of making of making
paintings
and even though i push against it in
some ways and people understand it or
don't
understand it faculty understand it or
don't understand it back then
um that that is that that is that
language
and so i'm like trying to take that and
make it my own
and do what i do what i want to do um
with it
but i the
the the audience question is complicated
for me now
because there's one way where i could
say the audience of my paintings are the
people who buy my paintings
no no
not anymore i can't i can't that that
can't be
i that can't be it and so because i come
from that tradition where
as painters we're literally taught it's
weird because this is contradiction
we're taught that you're not supposed to
be thinking about the audience
you're not supposed to be thinking about
that you're supposed to be thinking
about
you and like how you think about the
piece and how you come to the piece
it's different from like theater where
you're always thinking about the
audience and how like
the audience is going to receive and
think about a piece what where are you
going to be on the stage in relationship
to where the audience is going to be
like that's a part of the art form
itself
i i now have to find different ways
to get to my audience
first audience is me always i'm always
my first audience like
i'm never gonna make a thing that the
rest of the world thinks is amazing but
i hate it
i'm just not willing to put stuff out in
the world like that it doesn't matter to
me what everybody else thinks in that
way
i'm working on finding ways to get after
my
myself as a first year audience get to
this other this other
my folks like my folks to see it because
the work is now at a place where
i'm i'm happy to have the success that
i'm having
but it means there's a limited number of
people who are living with my work now
and those limits i will i will accept
the piece though i mean if
if if you want to expand that limited
number work on the wall stop plan
we have to find ways i have to find ways
to reconnect and so what do we do like
we do these prints we do these books
like you know i'm constantly asked to do
these talks and lectures
and honestly i'm i i evaluate whether i
do a talking lecture based on
the access of the people who asked me to
do it if you have a lot of access i'm
likely to say no
if you don't have access i'm likely to
say yes
because like the those often are the
communities
that at very least reflect my experience
which is where my quote audience comes
from
even when thinking about myself right
what would i have thought about this
growing up where i grew up
you know 30 40 years ago like what what
would have been my experience
like we said before what is mom what
does mom think about this what is my
like my mother's reaction to duane's
piece
that was powerful way way more
impacting than reading roberta smith
review
of my work way way way more impact
i think that's a powerful note to end on
and i think um claudia
okay crystal i just wanna because
i have all these questions that you
didn't ask and because you brought a
preferred
spin she called it okay sorry you called
you you were conceptual objects did you
how did you feel about that
who did me i did no roberta smith
oh she called them conceptual objects
yeah i was
i think because they cut they have cut
outs but i was
as i was thinking about that phrase i i
thought i wonder what titus think about
that
well because i know the
language of art review
i'm going to accept the compliment she
was trying to give me
okay how's how's that like i think
i i know what her intention was
and we don't have to rehash this but
what i will say is that it does go back
to this idea
of of formal versus political
it goes it goes back to that it's she's
she's elevating it
in her mind and her mind that's what
that's what's happening
so i'll accept that compliment because
it's a lot more than that
because the phrase brought to me like a
david hammons
and you're working david hammond seems
so different to me so
that's why i was curious what you what
you thought yeah
thank you both thank you both thank you
this was um this was cool you know it's
it's
it's actually important i do think one
of the reasons i was i was excited about
doing this is because it was the three
of us
and you know and i think about how we
create historical records
and how the historical records from the
past you know you read a letter
from from from from from richard wright
to gwendolyn brooks and it's like
man i mean richard wright is like
talking about the guggenheim and you
think
it just means something to be a part of
a a conversation between the two of them
and it means a lot to be a part of a
conversation with the two of you
thank you and it's amazing to be able to
witness that conversation
so i want to thank you all three for
agreeing to do it
and doing it so beautifully um and i i
know we're in this zoom world but i do
like to take a moment
to ask people to unmute and to actually
clap
because i think we need to applaud you
your work and this conversation so